so what do you do to improve your metric
iterate all right talk to your users and
change if something's not working
there's a reason it's not working I
think the worst thing that happens when
metrics aren't going well when the two
worst things I would say that people do
when their metrics aren't moving in the
right direction they stick their heads
in the sand and say no I understand
better than anyone elses I'm just gonna
keep down the same path which typically
doesn't work because you're getting
signals and the other worst thing that
people do is people switch metrics
people say oh well I know we were
supposed to focus on revenue but it's
not wrong so we're gonna focus on users
right because they focus on or press or
money raised or something because that's
something they can point to as a sign of
success because honestly it's really
really hard to admit that you're not
doing something right and that you're
failing especially as an entrepreneur
because your ego is actually pretty
important again to push you through
those walls but you can't let it get in
the way of change you have to understand
what you're getting wrong and fix it and
when you iterate to do a/b testing or
any other type of testing it depends I
mean a B testing is specifically really
about changing something on your website
you know doing two different versions to
see what happens to click rates if you
have a different picture or something
like that so that can be useful but
typically you need to go deeper than
that right you have to tinker with the
guts of what you're doing you know if
you're losing customers because your
server load times are too slow a be
testing won't help you there you
actually have to re-engineer what you've
built if you have the completely wrong
features EB testing you know you could
do the thing that I that we that we used
to do which is you put the dead link and
see if people click on it that's a form
of a/b testing right but you have to
build a whole new thing and I think
about a/b testing as incredibly powerful
but very much about incrementalism and a
lot of the time when it comes to
iterating your product you have to take
leaps you have to take so this is
actually I think of something I didn't
say before which is listen to your
customers feedback we don't build
exactly what they say you have to make
the intuitive leap from the feedback you
get to what they're going to need in the
future and what they're going to want in
the future a be testing won't
you there strong product vision well so
when do you know that you can launch
there's no way to know
I think precisely I think the main thing
is just launched already right if if
you've built that thing that is useful
even in the smallest way to your users
put it out there because if you wait for
some sort of monolithic launch you're
gonna be too late I think this is this
is one of the key differences between
how startups launch and how software is
made today versus ten or fifteen years
ago there's a great book about into it
I'm totally blanking on the name of the
book but sort of the story of Intuit and
how they beat Microsoft money because
they did which was crazy that the small
startup be Microsoft and I remember very
distinctly you know they had to launch a
useful product it's tough because it was
you know accounting software and tax
software I think it wasn't tax off for
at that point was you know personal
money management software and needs a
lot and they did this Herculean effort
to get the whole thing done and like you
know the the CTO worked for a week
straight without sleep kind of thing and
the reason they had to do that is
because they actually had to press
floppy disks right you had to get the
software onto a floppy disk and make and
the whole company came in to press
floppy disks and one of the times they
did this there was a bug they realized
afterwards they all came back the next
weekend repressed them sent him out and
so that was this idea that you had to be
ready to launch and like really ready
with everything done and with that led
to is a hell of a lot of upfront
investment with no idea whether or not
the product would work now because of
the internet you can basically deploy
something smaller and then add to it
over time and so we tell startups again
and again and again just launch
something because a lot of the time the
thing that you think will be the next
you know step in your company's life
isn't and you won't know it unless
you're interacting with customers so so
a lot of entrepreneurs want to wait
until their feature already and oh yeah
like the last mile of feature is that
they have the right number of pixel
padding we're talking crazy things right
you know where people are delaying a
launch because they want a very specific
graphic you know they hired someone to
do
nobody cares it
you have that graphic right they care
whether or not the product works and
does something rights and what are like
for example the the bad things that you
forget to do in a launch or it should
wait too long well it has to work
hope you know sometimes people will
focus too much say on visual design and
the thing won't work it just won't load
you hit a button and nothing happens
right that's the worst thing that you
can possibly do because you get one
chance to make a first impression with
someone and it better be good
on the other hand you can launch as many
times as you want right no one will
remember you launched if they never saw
it right so it's okay just to put it out
there doesn't have to be a big splashy
thing just put it out there see what
happens and keep launching until people
notice and start to learn and start to
learn about you right so every time you
got a new feature you launched right
you're launching fresh until you hit
that point where people know about you